wenn du irgendwann mal mit deiner
freundin oder so kommen würde wie viel
müsste dann gewünscht der beuditzschule
ab mit kinder leiter max ertl selbst und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute wie lange haben die vorbereitung
für das heutige video genauer zu
allererst habe ich meine große kamera
den achten vergessen damp ladegerät
alter schwede der kleinen digitalkamera
aufnehmen hat ich glaube alles aufgebaut
was eigentlich egal er über den iphone
bildschirm selbst aufnimmt und dann hab
ich da mal ne stunde laden gesetzen den
iphone bildschirm aufzunehmen ist haben
jetzt aber hoffentlich auch alle
bekommen sollten alle funktionieren
deswegen herzlich willkommen bei einem
erotischen gastgeber an diesem abend
niemand geringeres als ich und damit
legen wir direkt los geht's direkt los
okay der unschuldige hasenfeld und dann
so eine frage was heißt ohne frage ganz
normale eigentlich mal wisst ihr alle
machen immer so ein theater aus liebe
und sex
wir sind heute einmal ganz direkt
größerer schussweite doch nicht zu
vernachlässigen aber ich würde
tendenziell wenn man sich nur für eins
entscheiden kann würde ich eher arsch
sein
lottes keeper hitz lot zu halten
wisst ihr warum leute ich weiß so viele
leute aus meiner uni schon noch in meine
videos rein um eine story wenn denn das
video gesehen dass wir nicht in der uni
de also auf youtube zuschauern will ich
erzählen aber ich habe einfach keinen
bock auf menschen möchten das ist okay
was finde ich an frauen an sehen dass
man keine story also schauen momentan
relativ paul dass du der youtuber den
momentan am meisten bot macht den
zuschauer nicht weiß geht mit einigen
von euch jungs auf dauer ich denke dass
der leser weile dieses mädel mit der
dritten folge steht bevor da irgendwas
passiert ist keine ahnung wie ist
eigentlich so ziemlich gold würde man
sagen und zwar sind es natürlich äußere
sachen selbstverständlich steht auch mit
rein aber auch humor ich kann nicht mit
leuten sein die einfach immer so todes
ernst wenn ich weiß davon gibt auch
genug weise aber das liegt für mich und
was mir auch wichtig ist dass die person
der kritik gestört hat war ich bin
selbst auch gestört ich mag gerne
bescheuerte unvernünftige sachen und
wenn irgendwer mit dem jäger langweilig
immer wieder ist von immer versuchte gar
kein preis aufzufallen und autos einfach
nicht hin
ok klasse frage glaube ich an die wahre
liebe
ich glaube nicht an solche begriffe um
ehrlich zu sein leute ich glaube einfach
dass jeder mensch so eigen ist weil
jeder mensch anders unserem leben erlebt
hat die konstanz villingen nehmen damit
wäre sehr ähnliche dna und sind auch im
gleichen haushalt aufgewachsen aber
trotzdem unterschiedliche erfahrungen
gemacht und wintern am ende auch einfach
anders deswegen würde ich sagen dass es
keine menschen auf der welt gibt diese
zu 100 m gleich sind und weil wir gleich
zusammen passen aber ich glaube es gibt
schon einige leute die wirklich gut
zusammen passen zum beispiel
[Musik]
viele leute also noch mal so eine
umfrage zu diesem thema erstes mal war
dass pippa po ich will nach wie vor
nicht in alter seine geschichte erzählt
und zwar kann ich dazu sagen dass früher
deswegen so mega mega mega mix gestresst
hab ich habe eine klasse übersprungen
wird früher eingeschult deswegen war der
jüngste meiner klasse radlader mal
körperlich und gedanklich schon viel
weiter als wichtigen zu dir ersten
freundin und ich habe noch ein kleiner
tipp für ja und hat mir so unfassbar
viel druck gemacht sagte motto junge
gebrauchte freundin muss man erst mal an
so das wird echt langer zeit und das
geht ewig so leute das gegenteil richtig
krank
letzten endes wird wahrscheinlich
relativ spät wird manche sagen und es
war okay meine erste beziehung also
allgemein muss erstmal überhaupt nicht
der betriebs menschlichkeit loser tätig
bin froh wieder vor den kann so die
erste bisschen längere beziehung war
glaube ich mir fünf aber das war halt
nur so nach dem motto ja ich krieg das
war eine freundin der mutter nicht als
problem ist aber schon länger wurde
schon mal betrogen leute nicht dass
wirst hab ich schon mal betrogen also es
gab noch mal so eine story erzählt wird
die fast jeden sommer urlaub auf die
gleichen ort die insel und haben daher
eine große clique aus mädels und jungen
jahren wenig um den heißen brei herum
ich hatte irgendwas mit einer dicht mega
cool fand die war wirklich wirklich
wirklich cool
und dann ein oder zwei abende später war
mir halt bei einer anderen irgendwie vor
trinken und dann hat sich irgendwas
entwickelte aber dadurch nicht auch mega
schlecht gefühlt ohne wird weil ich
beide wirklich leiden kann email des
allgemein ja alles cool jetzt entspannt
ja aber ich persönlich hab mich voll
aufgeregt habe ich deswegen dem moment
auch experten aber du kannst betrogen
langsam ist ein richtig guter vater
ich glaube ich ein richtig guter vater
als
und ich würde sie zwei kinder aber wenn
man nur ein kind hat leute ganz
gefährlich dann denkt des kindes befand
sich auf der ganzen welt und ist der der
scheich von persien und alles wissen
welche notenbank
deswegen hat die miteinander spielen
können sollen
was ich machen könnte viel geld alles
klar leute damit endet auch dieses tief
fielen dann wirst du schauen hier oben
findet ihren kanal den rebellen
gehaltenen bist du schon es geht an alle
die heute was einige seiner heimat bis
zum nächsten video